in wallace i what one of the things i
think is so interesting about him
is that i think he is a great observer
of the contemporary world and he's a
very funny writer and he's really funny
but he's a great observer of the of the
contemporary world and what he thought
uh was at the core of the contemporary
world was this constant temptation to
diversion through entertainment
that's a different story than
heidegger's story about efficiency and
optimization but it's the other side of
it like what is this tension temptation
sort of diverting us from
the ability to be more efficient
so you know you're tempted to go you
know watch some stupid film
or television show or something that's
dumb and not really very interesting but
you read that temptation as a temptation
precisely in virtue of it's taking you
away from your optimizing your your
existence and so i think there are two
sides of the same coin i think he's
brilliant at describing it i think he
thought it was a desperate position to
be in that it was it was something that
we needed to confront
and find a way out of
and his characters are trying to do that
you